one problem 96 problem 96 and it says
1/2 plus open brackets 2/3 times 3 8
divided by 4 minus 9 16 so this is just
do you know order of operations and can
you deal with fractions so let's see 2/3
times 3/8 to see the 3s cancel out and
the 2 and the 8 become 1 over 4 1 over 4
divided by 4 let's see we're going to
suit 1/2 so that's becomes 1/2 plus 1/4
divided by 4 that's the same thing as
times 1/4 minus 9 over 16 so that is
equal to 1/2 plus 1 over 16 minus 9 over
16 and that doesn't matter what order we
do it in but since everything's in 16 so
let me write this in 16 so this is 8
over 16 plus 1 over 16 minus 9 over 16
so that's equal to 8 plus 1 minus 9 all
over that 16 plus 9 minus 9 that equals
zero choice e all that work to get to 0
next problem
97 water consists of hydrogen and oxygen
and the approximate ratio by mass of
hydrogen to oxygen so hydrogen to oxygen
is equal to 2 to 16 approximately how
many grams of oxygen are there in 144
grams of water okay 144 grams of water
that means that the oxygen and the
hydrogen is equal to 144
so that means oxygen plus hydrogen is
equal to 144 right they say 144 grams of
water or not you know when you have 144
grams of hydrogen so when you add these
together you have 144 and then they tell
us that the the ratio of hydrogen to
oxygen is to 216 or another way to write
you could say Hydra
over oxygen is equal to 2 over 16 which
is another way of saying 1 over 8 right
and so you could say and they want to
know how many grams of oxygen so we want
to solve for oxygen so we want to
substitute for hydrogen so we could say
hydrogen is equal to 1/8 the oxygen
right I just multiplied both sides times
oxygen so if hydrogen is equal to 1/8
oxygen you have oxygen plus 1/8 oxygen
let me make sure that's right yeah
hydrogen to oxygen yep
is equal to 144 and see if you view this
as 8/8 right one oxygen is same thing is
8/8 so you get nine eight oxygen is
equal to 144 so you get oxygen is equal
to 144 times 8 over 9c does 9 go into
144 think it should let me see how many
times is 9 3 definitely does this is 12
times 12 so 3 will go into 144 3 will go
into 144 48 times right nine goes into
144 nine goes into 144 1 954 16 times so
this is equal to 16 times 8 over 1 which
is what that's equal to 250 no that
can't be right
two oxygen now you can't have more more
grams of oxygen you can't have more
grams of oxygen than you do let me see
I've made a mistake someplace hydrogen
to oxygen is equal to 2 to 16th hydrogen
oxygen is equal to 2 to 16th which is 1
to 8 oxygen plus hydrogen is equal to
144 you get nine eight oh I see my
mistake
that's good I've been making a lot of be
careless mistakes made many take home
rest 9/8 equals oxygen over
sorry nine eight oxygen is equal to 144
so oxygen is equal to 144 times nine
over 8 sighs times 8 over 9 I was doing
it right so what did I where's my mister
okay so 144 times 8 over 9 that's equal
to oh I just made a mistake at the very
last step nine goes into 144 16 times 16
times 8 is in 256 it's it's 128 that was
my mistake so there was 128 grams of
oxygen ice made a mistake right at that
last step all right
and that's choice D question 98 98 if x
times 2x plus 1 is equal to zero and
they also tell us that X plus 1/2 times
2x minus 3 is equal to 0 then X is equal
to what so this is interesting
x times 2x plus 1 is equal to 0 that
means that either X or 2x plus 1 has to
be equal to 0 right so one of these has
to be equal to 0 but then X plus 1/2
times 2x plus 3 this tells us that one
of these have to be equal to 0 so if X
is equal to 0 then this has to be the
one that's equal to zero so either this
and that is equal to 0 or right did you
see that because well I guess both of
these could be equal to 0
I remember we multiply them out let me
see maybe I'm going down the wrong path
if I multiply these out I get 2x squared
plus 2 is equal to 0 if I multiply these
out I get x times 2x which is 2x squared
x times minus 3 minus 3 X 1/2 times 2x
so it's plus X and then 1/2 times minus
3 minus 3 halves is equal to 0 so I get
I get what 2x squared minus 2x right 3x
plus X is minus 2x minus 3 halves
is equal to zero actually I think I mean
it's two x times two x plus one that's
not right that's 2x squared plus X is
equal to zero fair enough so let's let's
do a little we know 2x squared so we
could just write that 2x squared is
equal to minus X and then substitute
this information in here so we get minus
X right - x squared is equal to minus X
do it - X minus two X minus three halves
is equal to zero so you get minus 3x
minus 3x is let's add three-halves to
both sides is equal to three-halves and
then divide both sides by minus 3 you
get X is equal to three-halves times
minus 1/3 so that is equal to minus 1/2
and that is choice B next problem 90
where am I 9999 on a scale that measures
the intensity of a certain phenomenon a
reading of n plus 1 corresponds so n
plus 1 corresponds to an intensity this
10 times the intensity corresponding to
a reading of n so n plus 1 is equal to
10 times the reading of just an N on
that scale the intensity corresponding
to a reading of 8 is how many times as
great as the intensity corresponding to
reading of 3 okay so if you call a
reading of 3 I don't know a reading of 3
let's call that a 1 a reading of 4 is
going to be a 10 times the reading of 3
a reading of 5 is going to be 10 times
that so 100 reading of 6 is going to be
10 times that or a thousand a reading of
7 is going to be 10 times that or 10,000
and then a reading of 8 would be 10
times that so it'd be a hundred thousand
a hundred thousand which is not one of
the choices let me make sure I
I'm reading that on a scale that
measures the intensity of certain
phenomenon a reading of n plus 1
corresponds to intensity there's ten
times the intensity corresponding to a
reading of n right so a reading of four
is ten times the intensity of a reading
of three and reading a five is ten times
that fine on that scale the intensity
corresponding to a reading of eight is
how many times as great is how many
times as great as the intensity
corresponding to a reading of three
right reading a four would be ten times
as great a reading of five would be a
hundred times as great reading of six
would be a thousand times as great right
thousand times is great oh yeah I kept
for this yeah a hundred thousand was
just ten to the fifth right ten to the
fifth power five zero so that is choice
C confusing myself unnecessarily and I'm
out of time see in the next video let me
stop this one